حرب ضد واحدة من أكبر
سلال الخبز في العالم ،
الأراضي الزراعية الخصبة في أوكرانيا الآن ، تظهر
لقطات طائرة بدون طيار عسكرية في ساحة المعركة
حصلت عليها حصريًا CNN المدفعية الروسية
تقصف حقول القمح وهي تحرق موسم الحصاد الصيفي ،
تسابق المزارعون السود لحماية محاصيلهم
حتى غزو روسيا لأوكرانيا كانت أوكرانيا
الخامسة في العالم  أكبر مصدر للقمح ،
هذا يبدو وكأنه نوع من
الذخيرة هنا
الآن يحصد المزارعون الأوكرانيون محصولًا
مميتًا يقول ميخائيل إن هذه قطع من
الصواريخ الروسية
التي جمعوها من الحقول
يأخذني في جولة في مزرعته
التي سيظهرها  نحن ،
هذه قذيفة أخرى تضرب
فدادين من القمح في انتظار حصادها على
مرمى البصر من قصف المدفعية الروسية ،
هذا أمر خيالي تمامًا ،
نحن
وسط حطام المعارك السابقة
ناقلات جند مدرعة
ومركبات عسكرية ومن ثم لديك مزارعون
هنا يحصدون القمح بشكل صحيح  الآن يمكن أن يحدث هذا
المركبات التي دمرت هنا
بالعودة إلى شهر
شباط (فبراير) قبل ذلك بكثير ، لكننا نشهد أيضًا
هذه الحفر الناتجة عن ضربات القذائف
التي
قيل لنا أنها
ربما حدثت خلال الأسبوعين الماضيين
على الرغم من التهديدات التي لا يزال هؤلاء المزارعون الشجعان
يجلبونها في حصادهم فقط
لمواجهة عقبة أخرى
وهي  3000 طن من القمح
من حصاد العام الماضي
لا يمكنه بيع هذا القمح لأن
الجيش الروسي قد
أغلق موانئ أوكرانيا ، لذلك لا توجد طريقة
لبيع هذا إلا بخسارة هائلة في
الموانئ الأوكرانية حيث كانت السفن تحمل ذات مرة
ملايين الأطنان من الحبوب.  شهر إلى
الأسواق العالمية التي
حاصرتها البحرية الروسية الآن ،
أدى ازدحام جذوع الأشجار إلى ارتفاع أسعار المواد الغذائية العالمية ،
مما أثار تحذيرات من المجاعة في
بعض أفقر دول العالم
الشهر الماضي ، أجبر الجيش الأوكراني
القوات الروسية على التخلي عن
جزيرة الأفعى الأوكرانية في البحر الأسود ،
وانتصار جزيرة الثعابين.  حررت
القنوات المؤدية إلى نهر الدانوب ، وأعادت أوكرانيا
تنشيط موانئ الحقبة السوفيتية على هذا
الممر المائي كبديل
للجفاف  يقول الخبراء إن
النهر لا يمكنه التعامل إلا مع جزء بسيط من
شحنات أوكرانيا قبل الحرب
هذا الأسبوع ، حيث قال وفدا أوكرانيا والروسية والأمم المتحدة
المجتمعين في اسطنبول ، إنهم
توصلوا إلى اتفاق من حيث المبدأ لاستئناف
شحنات الحبوب عن طريق البحر ،
لكن المزارعين الأوكرانيين ما زالوا يواجهون
الموت.  تهديدات على الأرض تجعل
زراعة المحاصيل في العام المقبل أمرًا محفوفًا بالمخاطر بالنسبة للكثيرين ،
يتعهد هذا المزارع في الخطوط الأمامية بعدم
التخلي عن
جنودنا ويقاتل ويموت
للتخلص من هؤلاء المحتلين ، كما يقول ،
إننا بحاجة إلى إطعام جنود بلادنا
ومساعدة العالم بأسره  مع طعامنا
لهذا السبب سنواصل
العمل ، يطلق على مزرعته الجبهة الثانية
في هذه الحرب المميتة إيفان واتسون سي إن إن في
جنوب أوكرانيا